thank you good afternoon everyone good
afternoon members ladies and gentlemen
those of you following us on youtube
welcome to the external overview and
scrutiny committee meeting on wednesday
the 9th of february
item number one apologies
chair we've had apologies from kenton
baker and councillor hawkins
thank you and we'll go straight on to
the minutes i'll take the page of my
page
stop me if anybody's got anything
um i'll do the numbers at the bottom
that's page three
page four
page five
page six
page seven
page eight
page nine
doing that and i don't know why unless
you think anybody likes second one
i'll check them
out
all those in favor
thank you
um item number three public
participation you don't have any
um
item number four which is the action
list
89 is complete
91.
is ongoing
and um
109
send an invitation to the office
service manager to highlight on the
ground maintenance in-house
i haven't progressed that one so that's
all i was going to look at the forward
plan for next year okay yeah that's
brilliant
brilliant thanks karen
um
oh citizens advice that was at our last
meeting that has gone forward to cnr
it went the next that same week
they went to the united
for a st
with a report
um because the recommendation was made
last time without any information as to
what their cab need or may require so
it's going to come back
to this committee at a future date okay
thank you stacy
[Music]
because i can hardly hear you i haven't
got a microphone but i should speak up
councillor pennington thank you i don't
know why did you not feel like you
wanted you don't require much yes
okay apparently they don't only need one
well they had one yesterday
obviously
that's all right absolutely the chair
was told to stick the end in properly
i don't have one of those to stick
anywhere today
number five declarations of interest
members with interest should refer to
the agenda item and describe the nature
of their interest when the item is
discovered
discovered considered
maybe forget what i'm doing now um item
number six agreements of the agenda part
one and part two we don't have any part
two so we're okay there
um urgent matters brought forward with
permission of the chair i don't have any
right so and then on to the main event i
think which is a
presentation today on um
the way our national health service is
forming between uh north devon district
and um our d and e um we have some
speakers today
will they pop up if i say their names
sue mills and catherine allen
so once they start speaking they should
appear
yeah i can hear you afternoon can you
hear me
yeah
yeah um one of my colleagues sahara hyde
is struggling to get in i don't know if
the if there's a lobby like there is in
teens there's no one waiting currently
looks like i'm doing her bit too then
let me just if you wouldn't mind just
going 20 seconds i'll just text her
no that's fine
um catherine now i'll send her the link
again and it would be sahara hyde and
catherine allen speaking today so i'll
just send that through to her and
hopefully
are you next door to her soon
no unfortunately not but i will uh i'll
just quickly uh put that in teams or
email to her as well at the same time
i'm um i'm able to start but um how long
have i got chair
as long as it takes really i think um
colleagues needs to be gone by four
ideally i need to be gone by four but
so what we've done is we've produced
just a few slides together and but
prioritized your questions so given made
sure we had enough time so we've roughly
allocated we've sort of guested about
half an hour does that sound okay
fine that's fine great
so if she does manage to get in um i
will be joined by zahara hyde he's the
program director for the new hospitals
program which is the government um
capital scheme for new hospital
buildings my name's catherine allen i'm
the director of strategy for north devon
and the raw devon and exeter i'm a i'm a
new newly joined
postholder but i have worked for the
northern demon healthcare trust for
about 14 years so um
um
um we we will be talking through the you
know we'll be giving you a brief today
about the merger and the new hospital if
that's okay
so do i do a chris witte next slide
so um
i'm aware that
the nhs personnel occasionally resort to
jargon so please do stop me if i go
native and use words you're not familiar
with
um but i think just the context for us
is really important so north devon
district hospital is the most remote
acute hospital in england the only uh
the
most remote one is on the isle of wights
at mary's but so we are we are you know
you know this we lit we all live in this
community and and you know that it takes
an hour and a half to get to exeter or
taunton so
we feel our remoteness quite strongly
but it also makes us really resilient we
have a a really good family atmosphere
of care in north devon so there are pros
and cons of being remote but i'll talk
in a little while about why it's causing
us a challenge we know our population
needs consistent access to high quality
urgent care as employers in the region
as society we need our population of 170
odd thousand to have a e accessed 24 7.
we also need to have them to have ct mri
and all of the other x-ray diagnostics
as well as maternity services as a
minimum now i don't mean as a minimum as
in that's what we're aiming for but
these are the though in nhs parlance
that is that is the core service and
then you have all of the other ones
around it which are in the hospital
service and in the community
and most of our buildings um have not
changed since the 1970s so what you're
looking at on this slide is is what was
built in 1970. now inside with our ward
we've had a really successful ward
refurbishment scheme and our awards are
really tip-top
uh you know built to the height for
refurbished to the highest spec but some
of the fabric of our building is is
really um you know it's aging it's you
know it's what you'd expect from a 50
year old building that gets a lot of use
and
what we what we're feeling and what we
are encountering on a daily basis is
it's preventing development the the
walls and the constraints of the
building fabric is is preventing us from
modernizing our health care provision
next slide please
here's a bit of a summary of the key
issues uh for us as a healthcare service
uh in our community we are heavily
dependent on local on locums and what
they're they are basically agent agency
consultants and you'll have heard us say
this for many years because it's been a
recurrent workforce challenge
um that when when you know bigger trusts
experience workforce challenges places
like northern devon which is more remote
get get
the sharp end of that
it's not that we haven't tried you you
our recruitment materials are amazing
and they're really successful when they
work but we are repeatedly failing to
recruit to some of our key specialties
we're also
as you know so i'm getting messages from
my team they just can't get in that's
fine but you will also know that um we
live in a rural and deprived community
these health inequalities particularly
during coburg were really stark um and
exposed us
as a council as both councils you will
you will understand what i'm saying we
have a really different um a really wide
life expectancy gap between some of our
most deprived and least deprived areas
we have um north devon district hospital
was included in the in the new hospital
program because of its significant and
rising
uh we call it backlog maintenance burden
so 50 of this is deemed high priority
critical which means that there is a
risk that um services will oh look
there's sahara there's a risk that
services will not
clearly getting some technical support
um
there's a risk that um the the
maintenance the lack of you know the
inability to maintain office services
will start to impact care and you know
giving you an example of theaters which
is one of our most high highest intense
clinical environments they haven't been
outdated since the 1970s when the
building was built
and i just want to
end by saying none of this uh it takes
away from the fact that all of us are
committed um to the the fact that
northern devon needs its local area i
don't want you to read any of this that
these are issues that mean we give up
or that we you know we um don't keep
striving to make sure this this our
local health services are really
successful and really vibrant
next slide please
so i'm um if i talk about um
the factors that have led to the
proposal of the merger with rd and why
we
think it's
the right time for this sahara will come
in um seamlessly into taking over some
of the issues that you know some of the
enablers in our buildings that are gonna
um help this so
ardini um for those of you who've been
uh as a customer of our services will
know that rd have provided services in
north devon for decades and that is in
cancers renal
ear nose and throat um
teeth and maculofacial so we have had a
partnership with rde for many years
where their clinicians travel up to
north devon to deliver care we also our
population also rely on circle
issues
um home schooling is amazing um we also
have um
our population is served by rdd in
exeter to where they can access that's
their nearest local access to specialist
services and rd we're really lucky
argini is a teaching hospital really
known for its research and specialisms
and genomics it's it's got a national
reputation for some really good stuff
um but in 2018 for those of you with
with um who are here at that point um
there were some leadership and clinical
concerns at northern devon healthcare
trust we were struggling we er that the
trust was seeking mutual aid which means
where we were asking other hospitals for
help with some of our key services
um
and it was mainly down to our workforce
that that that was leading to that and
some of our financial and performance
concerns so rd came in in 2008 um to
support the trust uh it we
came in i think you have all met james
brent and suzanne tracy the chief exec
and chair and they are they take on
joint board and chief exec roles and and
that was then joined by a joint board
and joint executive team and due course
so since 2018 we've shared a lot of the
leadership positions with um rd e and
that has really stabilized um the local
service provision and given um and you
know started the resolution of quite a
number of our challenges
so if i ask the next slide please
so yeah so so um
it's really helpful to just
give you some really granular detail
about what's happened since 2008 that
makes us feel that the merger is the
right thing and how
how challenging it is for
hospital trust to operate in a in a
rural remote environment and and um why
we think this is the right time to merge
right now
so the first thing that happened in 2018
was the stabilization of maternity now
we know there were lots of media reports
at the time about the challenges in that
service um an ird immediately brought in
a clinical lead so it's the highest um
clinical consultant across both trusts
and then we
employed rotational consultants so these
are
doctors who rotated their time between
north devon and um
rd and that was really successful and
it's given us a real sense of confidence
that actually this is a model that could
work for many other services we also
stabilized ent so you'll remember that
um ent services with the retirement of a
consultant it meant we had no um service
in north devon for a little while with
rd support we brought back a rotational
service and now we have uh clinicians
visiting north devon to deliver that
service
to our population same with neurology
and cardiology so i think one of the
things that um
you know you have to look at motivations
here don't you but what what ardenee was
finding was that the north devon
population was um trying to access its
services down in rd and actually from
the rd perspective it was far more far
better for it to support north devon
services and make sure that you know
local people have local access which
meant that everyone got the care they
needed in a timely way
so we move on we're moving on now to
tackling the other services with the
greatest workforce challenge and this is
not a new phenomenon for the nhs um so
it is you will hear every um hospital
talk about workforce challenges um at
the moment
now it's in the news isn't it with the
elective you know the recovery
people are wondering you know where the
capacity is going to come from so this
is a real real challenge for all of the
nhs at the moment but i think one of the
things we've shown since since the
since the relationship with arden is
that you if you put um rotational
clinical posts it's actually really
attractive for clinicians because they
get a real difference of a variety of
experience they can work down in the um
rd e with the really with the deep
specialisms and the big teams and the
teaching hospitals and they can come up
and get a completely different
experience working in north devon
district hospital patients are still the
same but the context is different and i
think one of the things we've started to
encourage is that joint clinical
leadership so like the model um that we
took with maternity where a joint
clinical lead took an overview of a
north and east devon population
that's that's working really well and
it's recently
you know a year ago we put the same
model in place in oncology and it means
that you can start clinicians start test
to view the population as a whole
which means that more cares brought up
the road more cares delivered remotely
for the benefit of the north devon
population
um and it's not all one way so um one of
the things that the north devon team are
really proud of is the fact that they
have ideas and a small hospital that's
been um sometimes at the forefront of
workforce challenges innovates
and is very creative about the way they
solve challenges um and there's a thing
or two that they they are teaching the
larger hospital down the road so i think
you know it's um just in case for the
better just in case anyone thought it
was just the big hospital tip um
it's not one way this is a partnership
and i think um if you can remember the
red line marches um that were um with
save a hospital service back in 2008
there was a real fear about local
services and that is not you know that
is not there it's in the same degree
in our local community but um
people are feeling more secure about the
future of the local services and we are
getting really positive feedback from
the community about the arrangements we
have in place and what they are seeing
us deliver together so
i'd be interested in your view about
whether that whether that resonates with
you
um and more recently through covered you
know covered taught us um a lot about um
how to deliver care rapidly and how to
re-engineer our services
going online doing appointments via
video and um remotely all of that was
done together we shared everything we
shared all of the government guidance
that came out at five o'clock which is
probably the same for you as it was for
us all of that was absorbed and dealt
with together so you know there's a lot
to be said for for sharing a problem
together
if i could have the next slide please
and as i as i alluded to just a minute
ago with sable hospital services and you
know making sure that the community
understood what what our challenges were
but also what we were doing about them
um we we did a review of hospital
services so we asked people back in 2019
what was important to them about local
services and we used that feedback to
inform the organizational form that we
that we wanted to pick we have there's
many options you can pick uh in the nhs
we could formally merge we could keep
going on a contractual basis where we
sub-contracted services
we felt because of the remoteness of
north devon we really needed a formal
partner to to to be with us
delivering care locally so that's how
the option of the merger was was arrived
at um through the engagement that we did
with with everyone in the community
um and
you know and
i think part
people have views about mergers don't
they and i'd again be interested to see
but it but we really felt that our
experience since 2018 has been in an
informal partnership and we recognize
that it has limitations and that is why
we're looking to formally merge because
what that does is it binds the two
organizations together it makes that
shared shared problem something that's
natural across across both trash so that
it's natural that people think of or our
clinicians think of the north and east
population as one as opposed to
thinking of it completely separately in
silos
so next slide please
[Music]
so that i'm nearly at the end so you'll
be happy pleased i'm about to hand over
to zahara but what we
what what i'm you know what i'm really
happy to talk to you about is over the
past four years working with our dne and
north devon together there are
a couple of things that become really
apparent to us north devon will benefit
from the strengths of a bigger trust
whereas whether that's access to
research the combined resources
resilience of you know small teams
joining together to make more resilient
services
um but equally our dna will benefit from
the small you know comes from a small
hospital being really agile
getting things done quickly we will for
the taxpayer benefit we we have got it
we can see a line of sight to more
efficient services we'll reduce the um
the duplication we will streamline
services for patients
and we will reduce our back you know the
cost of our back office so all of the
corporate support services that come
with merging services
and you know can't um
underestimate the importance of patient
confidence
it's really important to us that people
feel confident in in the future of their
local services and part of that will be
you know will be evident when we see a
new build it fits a new building coming
but but also
the fact that the support of a larger
hospital just gives
everyone that confidence
and also
everyone's changing the way that they
deliver care i know the council is
everything's coming online you can book
you know ask for new recycling bins
online it's exactly the same for us in
in our sphere of public sector
more and more will be done online you
know we have got
we're going to come on to this in a
minute but we have a shared agenda with
the council about digital inclusion and
how we how we support our community to
come with us now it won't be for
everyone we have to make sure that we
are inclusive but it is a massive part
of people's expectations that we are
efficient with this
so we propose to merge on the first of
april which um i've got a big countdown
clock it's six weeks away
we will the name of the trust will
change but again we we engage with our
community on that across north and east
durban and the name came up from that
engagement i can't tell you now because
uh it's not legally not illegally able
to enhance it but you rest assured it
reflects the history and provenance of
both trusts
but you know but the most important
thing is that staff and patients and our
community see very little difference
this is a murder this is a corporate
merger
the services were staying the same
patient you know north devon patients
will still access services in north
dakota and that is the whole aim of this
murder is to make sure that local access
is maintained
and there's lots of um ongoing
engagement um with our with our
community groups such as involving
patient steering group and save our
hospital services and we meet regularly
and they've expressed their full support
for the murder so i think
we're feeling like this is the right
time to do it
um i don't want if i could go on to the
next slide
and it's not always that pleasant
talking about the downside but i think
it's quite important in this
because we were asked to articulate this
as part of the business case i thought i
would um share that share this with you
i think we
we know you know uh for those of you
who've been in north denver for a long
time this this is the second time that a
merger with ardenny has been proposed i
think the last time was in 2003
and what's different about this time is
that the clinicians are 100 behind this
they understand um the benefits they can
see
the um the benefits of this murder for
the patients
um so i think that there's a there's key
differences um this time around and also
the way we've approached the
true trust coming together as a
partnership where both trusts have got
something to bring to each other
is really healthy
um
i think there's just a
you know the counterfactual as they call
it is that you know we would lose the
momentum so all of the
you know the clinicians are currently
traveling up to north devon if the
merger weren't to succeed you know that
that would probably you know that would
inevitably fall away
and we would go back to being separate
trust we would increase costs because
we'd have to recruit a new board
north devon would be left back in that
same situation that it was in in 2017
with a worsening financial position and
performance position which no one wants
and we risk a deterioration in the
quality and resilience of care so
i think um
you know faced with that that the merger
really makes sense
so i think let me just say i think i am
now ready to hand over to sahara so just
just for zahara's benefit i have
introduced you and who you are zara but
perhaps you would like to
um
take over from here if if we could have
the next slide because um
we're talking about how we're going to
make it work
thank you catherine can you hear me okay
yes okay so i apologize about everybody
the ones in technology my computer
refused to load zoom no matter how hard
they tried so i'm now in a meeting room
by myself um billy lads um just talking
to you and as kathleen said we work very
closely together so whilst i'm taking
the lead on this new program of estates
work it's very much part of their to
variable strategic direction for the
trust so uh when i interviewed i said
i'd be joined at the hip with katherine
and indeed i am so if we can move on to
the next slide please
there you go so the name we've given to
this program of work is our future
hospital that in itself was a
consultation
and probably not the most original title
but it is exactly what this program is
about it's about not just ensuring the
future of the site here at north devon
district hospital but about building
acute services for the future as part of
this why the trust that catherine has
been talking about so this program of
work is a national program and apologies
to those you've heard me speak before in
this but i think it's helpful to get
everyone to the same place so in 2019 uh
the current government committee in this
spending round 20 20 24 3.7 billion but
not only that they also announced a new
health infrastructure program that was a
rolling program of capital investment
recognizing that these critical care
buildings need to be maintained and
managed well into the future so once our
program is not due to be built in this
funding cycle the treasury is already
committed strategically to future rounds
of investment according to what is
required
there were 40 hospitals announced in the
first wave of the program that runs
until 2030 so over a decade and north
devon district hospital is one of three
hospitals in the south west four
hospitals in the southwest um there's a
beneficiary i guess five if we go aboard
at the sunset as well i was just doing
them in the cornwall there um so
just as a county devon is extremely
fortunate to have been targeted with
three different investments but for
arsenal north devon district hospital
getting on that list was extremely
important and in july of last year our
board approved the strategic outline
case which is the first stage of
negotiating for the release of capital
investment from the treasury
next slide please
so in that strategic case we have to
make our case for change um and that
clearly hinged around that 18 states
some parts this hospital almost 50 years
old
i have to say that from an
infrastructure standpoint that's where
the major challenges lie the fabric of
our buildings is remarkably good because
our estates did do an amazing job
maintaining it
unlike many of the things in north devon
we have a lot to be proud of here on
this site but um the infrastructure and
the functional suitability has become
significantly outdated katherine
referenced the theaters if you can
imagine the technology we now have
available for surgery operating a
theater that is 40 percent below the
standard size for modern theater builds
um it's like playing musical chairs in
there not good and certainly not what we
want but we also recognize there's
growth in the marketplace because our
population is growing in a positive way
because people are moving into the area
families are growing but also in a more
challenging way because the demographic
is shifting towards an older population
and that older population are going to
live longer with more long-term
conditions that mean the healthcare
requirements are different and larger so
we have to be able to respond to all of
that and finally our case for change
highlighted the workforce challenges and
kathleen talked about a remote hospital
in north devon um whilst uh i myself
spent my childhood holidays at croix bay
but definitely an advocate for north
devon nevertheless as a place to live
and work we still have to encourage
support and make this a place that
people want to come and be and the
hospital itself has to be a site and an
organization people enjoy being part of
because it is challenging to recruit
this far away from some of the major
cultivations
so our first business case set out our
vision and it emphasized the change of
what's called backlog maintenance which
is a technical term describing the
inevitable cost of continuing to
maintain
the fabric and infrastructure when it's
starting to deteriorate
tackling some of our functional
suitability looking at the overcrowding
that will inevitably result in our
existing buildings it's probably fair to
say overcrowding in buildings but not in
the actual site itself as a plot because
we are fortunate we have some land and
capacity to grow unlike some um and
obviously the workforce sustainability
issues and that growth i talked about
are key so that's why our case for
change is built around
next slide please
so we set out five ambitions and we've
consulted pretty widely on these both
among service users amongst the general
public around different key groups we've
talked to stakeholders other people in
the healthcare system but also
the wider sector to really understand if
these were the right things because at
the end of this program of work which is
a long program we wanted to know if we
had done right if we'd done well and if
we've delivered success so we listed
five ambitions
and they're probably fairly obvious but
i'll spell them out so fit for future
services because services clinical
services are evolving and changing and
need to but also the right care in the
right place and catherine talked about
maintaining local services our slogan
generally in our care model is local
where possible networks we're better so
we recognize that some services are
better delivered as a specialist service
in highly specialized centres of
excellence we're fortunate in our dne we
have some of that already and there are
some services we already deliver in that
way such as hematology um digitally
optimized i'll come back to that in a
minute but this is very much about
making care accessible
um fit for future workplace we want
staff's health
to be at the core there's been a lot of
publicity in the last 18 months two
years about what it's like to work in
the nhs and particularly for some of our
frontline style it is really important
we put them in front of the center
because all the evidence shows if you
care for your staff they're better able
to care for their patients
absolute natural fulfillment and fit for
futuristic state
fit for future estate covers many areas
it covers net zero carbon agenda and
making sure that we are um sustainable
but as green as we can be and that's an
anxious wide ambition it also covers
some of our personal ambitions as a
trust to make
this an accessible solution so
accessibility is a really broad area
we've been doing some work over the last
couple of months
again running some surveys and publicly
consulting stakeholder groups about
what's accessible means to them because
accessibility can be physical
accessibility how you actually get to
this site whether you've got a bus car
bicycle it can actually be site
accessibility how you get from the car
park to the front door it can be
navigating the building accessibility
can you even read the overhead signs or
work your way down to the two floors
below where the physiotherapy is hidden
or indeed is it about how you just
access information about care services
and how you get care which is about
digital channels and using every
possible way to communicate so we've
been really interested in the breadth of
response we've had on that and we will
be sharing that with our stakeholders
when we've been able to close and sift
through all of that information next
slide please
so building for the future although the
first stage is just an outline case for
change we still have to demonstrate that
we have thought about how we're going to
respond to those problems so this is our
first pass response which is a four
phase program of work that we believe
would help us deliver on those ambitions
and address the challenges and it starts
with phase zero and i'm happy to say
phase zero has not only been agreed and
invested in but is due to go live in
july of this year and that's the
integrated electronic patient record my
care which will be on a shared platform
with hopefully our most partner uh royal
devin alexa which will enable us to give
patients greater access to their own
information and managing their own care
but also enable us to deliver a much
more seamless and modern model of care
and to move forward so all of our
clinical staff
are both equally stressed and excited by
this no one likes to learn new systems
but they still absolutely recognize what
it would enable them to do in the future
and as i say that is part funded with
new hospital money
alongside nhsn's digital and
a local system
which has helped to step up to make that
uh deliverable so we're really excited
by that and then phase one which
probably wouldn't come on stream until
we actually get into the full approved
build phase will be the first stage of
building and that's about addressing our
on-site accommodation which is by far
the most um the poorest condition uh
estate we have here and therefore the
one that's least fit for purpose and
it's giving us the most headaches at the
moment in terms of being able to keep it
operational but also we want to take
this opportunity to expand and create
some staff wellbeing facilities within
that that will enable us to make the
site a more pleasant and uh
enjoyable place for staff to work um so
that's things like staff cafes and
health and wellbeing facilities and
we're doing some work at the moment to
validate exactly what we've put in there
and why but alongside that we also are
looking at other areas such as
accommodation for students which we've
always provided some on-site medical
student accommodation again can we
extend that as part of this all about
building for the future phase two then
is
a lot that's where we tackle our theater
problem and some of our other really
outdated pieces of estate where we just
can't recreate them functionally within
the existing building and then finally
phase three is refurbishing the vacated
spaces in our main tower and those of
you who've been to north denver district
hospital will know the hospital is
pretty much built around the nexus of
the main tower with the lady world
building for boys and children's down
beneath it we will be keeping that main
tower and effectively refurbishing the
areas vacated to create additional
inpatient ward bed space that would
enable us to meet future demand growth
yes
[Music]
please and
east
devon acute and community care
that purely um records um across the
health side
is there no linking in with social care
because that has been a really difficult
uh situation for health and social care
over the years
i note that since 2018
the department of health became the
department of health and social care
so is that community care inclusive of
social care is it just the health aspect
of
the service in the community from a
health point of view
is going to help me on this video
catherine so yeah initially it is um but
you're absolutely right to highlight the
fact that we need to get more integrated
and on a practical level the teams
often share the same patience you know
so you've got social care coming in and
then you've got healthcare coming into
the same houses in the in the community
so it is we need to get we need to do it
in stages don't we our digital strategy
is to get this patient record in for our
nhs uh services first and then look at
what happens um then look at the next
stage as well digital strategy because
it's not
it's not just about um
social care that's that's really
important there's other things like um
wearables you know people report
reporting their own blood pressure that
would benefit um social care and
anyone who's anyone who needs to spot
deteriorating health in their ca in
their patients or service users you know
so all of that all of that stuff is sort
of is
you know after the foundation of the
patient records starts to become a lot
more possible
i was just gonna add to that so i think
one of the key words here that we have
in our digital ambition is
interoperability um i think it would be
lovely to believe that all of the local
authorities and public sector agencies
including the nhs could come together
along with gp practices and all by one
system um we have never reached that
point and i'm not sure we ever will do
what i think we have will now recognize
is the requirement for interoperability
between those systems that allows data
to be shared across boundaries um
there's a lot of other issues that
prevent that it's not just technology
it's also about um
information governance if i can say that
in public i think it's a authority issue
at the best of times and we all wrestle
with it constantly but there's some
really good pilot work being done in
some of the other counties like
hampshire and dorset with the shared
care record where we have got social
care and nhs able to access the same
record there are some huge challenges if
i were honest for instance in fact
social care being a means-tested service
therefore includes financial information
in people's records nhs doesn't so these
are horribly nitty details but i just i
mentioned them just to spell out you're
absolutely right we want it i think
getting it to work is tricky what i do
think you have here in devon which is
amazing for me to see because i've
worked in other areas they don't is you
do have a really good integrated health
and social care team managing your
discharge and onward care process to
prevent admissions which means they are
working as one team
accessing the patient as one patient and
that is a step in the right direction
it's not where we want to be
does that answer your question
thank you yes
god excellent okay we go forward one
slide please
sorry councillor woodhouse would like to
ask you a question i just wanted to ask
again with regards to the digital and
patient records if you guys managed to
link them up a bit more yet because it's
my understanding that they're
inpatient uh medical records they're on
a different system to the community
medical records so they're not actually
compatible and don't work together as a
system as of yet and again as a
clinician you then can't access gp
is that i think that you anticipating
sorted or is that something you've
already done and what does that look
like
so yes um
they are on different systems uh now but
that's what we're saying um will happen
from that's what's coming in in july
2022 which is the
not only a shared assist the same system
for a cuting community in north but also
the same system across north and east
devon
thank you i mean
absolutely right the golden egg
is the gp record you know
getting you know joining up primary care
as well because you know gps are your
gateway into health services um but you
know that's that's for
possibly five years
thank you
okay so um let's talk about some of the
benefits of this program of work and
we've deliberately brought together here
all three because they are
interdependent so the merger with raw
devnet and north dakota healthcare trust
um with the enablers of this digital
investment in my care and the our future
hospital means that we believe that
across these three programs work we can
deliver a whole host of benefits uh and
in some ways we haven't spent a lot of
time trying to split out which one
delivers we know we need all three to be
able to deliver so i talked earlier
about accessibility um accessible care
is going to be dependent on all three of
these and the degree to which we can
deliver that will depend on getting or
through the solutions in each will
contribute partly but also i talked
about patients being able to manage some
of their own care now appreciate at some
end of the spectrum that's not
appropriate and not helpful but for a
lot of us for whom um you know ill
health can be um not necessarily an
opposite emergency requirement or indeed
an end of life but in fact something
which we do in their daily lives being
able to manage it is actually really
empowering
and similarly
technology has really found its day
during the pandemic for all the other
terrible things that we've been through
um the realization that not only has it
overcome and mitigated some of the
rurality for some of our patients of
having to drive an hour or so into the
hospital wrestle with car parking
negotiate their way to an outpatient
clinic to spend 10 minutes being told
their results are okay and ask their
questions when they could do all of that
in a virtual consultation telephone
consultation um interestingly the
feedback to our commerce team when they
did the post
first wave survey was very positive from
a lot of people and there are people for
whom that works and they want to keep
doing it so we are now reviewing our
outpatient services as a whole program
service by service identifying both for
first patient introductory but also
outpatient follow-up what is the right
range of options to offer people in
terms of consultation and that's just
one example catherine also mentioned
wearables remote
remote monitoring people being able to
self-monitor and input data so there is
a lot that has yet to be tackled on
technology but also um we believe that
we can encourage more integrated care so
you rightly ask the question about
community we can it is a nonsense isn't
it we're one trust across the community
with two different sets of patient
records so
absolutely we like to believe that the
more joined up we can be um the more for
patients they see seamless care uh even
though there are joints but there are
not theirs so i'm facilitating both
their self-care but also a more joined
up treatment approach is important next
slide please
um there's benefits for our staff we
talked about this a little bit and we're
really working hard to make sure that
all these elements deliver on that so
yes we want it to be a great place to
work and we want health and wellbeing to
be front and center but we've also
talked about the fact that north demon
district hospital as well as being a
small district general hospital does
have some areas of excellence we provide
some services across our region in fact
some of our surgery teams actually
provide national
services in terms of the specialist
areas that we have available so we do
have some amazing clinicians surgeons
and specialists who provide services
which we want to build on and we want to
shout about and we want to make sure
that people understand that you don't
just have to be a journalist to come
here you can be a specialist too but
specialists in the areas where we have
built excellence so there's lots of
things we can do that will help us to
really build we think the brand around
why it's good to work at the future
hospital
next slide please we got a couple more
promise
benefits for the trust obviously we do
have to deliver not just for our trust
but our local health and care system so
we do have to
deliver more efficiently effective care
i'll be honest with you i would be being
misleading if i said that the resources
are going to grow at the same speed as
population health care demand so unless
we can become more efficient and
effective
the financial gap endeavor will continue
to grow and we have to do our part to
improve that situation
but we also want to be able to deliver
our services in new ways we want to
actually be able to improve in just the
way our hospital hospital operates daily
where you know some of our facilities
are not adjacent to the areas where
people are working that can most help
because that's not the way the hospital
was built so the future offers a really
encouraging opportunity for our
clinicians to be able to deliver better
care and therefore for our trust to
function more effectively and finally i
mentioned earlier on
zero carbon ambition which is part of
the nhs wide ambition um there is lots
we've done at this trust already uh
combined heating power plants our solar
panels across the roof for those who've
ever been out there we've seen it from
the sky um you know we generate a fair
amount of energy ourselves
and we run
a very efficient hospital for an old
building but the opportunity to do
better is there
next time
so finally our benefits to our community
and is probably where we link you more
closely with our local authority
partners so absolutely bringing this
level of economic
opportunity into our local pact is an
absolutely amazing opportunity and
unsurprisingly lots of people want to
talk to us about it because it probably
is a once in a generational opportunity
for this locality but it is giving us
areas where we can identify
um really strong partnership is going to
deliver the best outcomes so we've
listed some of the areas there's a
sustainability one's a really good one
talking to north devon district council
and others at the moment about e-bike
systems and other ways in which we can
support some of the council's own drive
to generate an uptake of sustainable
transfer but also
looking at better transport links around
the system in terms of bus routes and
accessibility between community and
acute digital inclusion so we mustn't
obviously assume that anybody has access
to the um as my dad used to call it
world wide web you used to say the
capital w's i think as well um but
nevertheless it is really important to
understand how we make sure people do
have the kit equipment and um the
broadband there i say that was to access
those facilities and feel included um a
huge local regeneration opportunity
bringing this level of investment brings
with a huge responsibility to regenerate
our local area to create opportunities
for the youngsters who are currently in
college to create opportunities for
local firms which will be very much at
the forefront when we finally get to
planning implement implementation stages
but also we're bringing people into the
area to work we're going to grow as an
employer we're already one of the
largest employers here so areas like
meeting key worker housing conversations
we've already opened with local partners
and we'll continue to develop through
cancer in the team and our strategic
development of how we work together
next slide please
hoping
it's next steps it is so time scales um
when something is as large as this the
time scales can feel huge um but in
essence we're working towards a goal of
developing our detailed design and
business case for next summer what that
means for us
is that um there will be an awful lot of
consultation and conversations go on
there will be patient engagement
experience based co-design at some of
our pathways
discussions around what the build
options are what they may look like and
at the end of that period we will submit
a detailed design business case of what
we want to do and why we want to do it
into the new hospital program which
would then have to go to treasury
approval and the final stage in this
process which probably won't happen to
the beginning of 2024
is a full business case which is really
the implementation that's the signing of
the contracts for construction of
various phases and as you can see the
way we divide lenses up we can actually
deliver in phases which we think will be
a more manageable um fly the claim or
rebuilding it option for us um so that's
kind of the time scales we're sort of on
the
we mentioned the new digital patient
record also going live um our bills
window for our main bill for phase two
and three is 2025 to 2027.
so that probably gives you a sense of
the time frame we're operating on here
just five years to go before i can
castle ribbon i'm thinking next step the
next page i think is just the questions
am i right
yes so um thank you
any
thank you questions much ladies anybody
got any questions
oh
i knew shelley wouldn't let me down
that's a language um can i just
summarize that slightly will there be a
completely new hospital then
uh when all these phases are finished or
or is it just small parts of the
hospital being changed
so it'll be a big chunk of new coupled
with a lot of refurbishment of the old
so it would be a bigger building
per se so we're adding to the hospital
be the best way to describe it
and what we're adding is new build but
we're using some of the investment to
redesign some of what we've got left
behind
so we won't have a whole new hospital we
have a redeveloped site and the site
will look very different
particularly because obviously the
existing residences and so on will be
taken out and replaced with the health
and wellbeing cameras so i think when
you drive onto the site as a a local
resident it will look and feel very
different to what it does now but our
original main tower will still be there
front and center and dare i say i
suspect will still have its main
entrance but there may will be other
instances into the hospital for day case
patients surgical patients etc um in the
new bills
thank you chair is it have i got another
couple of questions is that all right
thank you
and
uh i know somebody that's moved down and
started working at northern hospital um
they were at the qe in
birmingham and um
they've said that at the moment working
in north devon everything's on paper
whereas she's come from an environment
where um everything was on the computer
drugs all the drugs that were allocated
etc etc so when you're talking about
digital records and everything will that
include
um
the way the staff operate all the time
in the hospital will will they be moving
fully to a
computerized system from this summer
yes
absolutely it's a massive cultural shift
and um
[Music]
it's great it's actually great to have
people with that experience who come in
from external trust because it means
that it's you know it's it means you've
already got a champion in that area who
understands what's about to happen so
yes i'm really pleased to hear
but yes that is what our intention is
and it will oh it will keep you know we
won't stop there
and um
is there a
will that um could north devon hospital
have um be a center of excellence in any
area could it be a teaching hospital for
any area i mean you said that there's
obviously
north devon will have things to offer
just like at the extra hospital but
could we be a center of excellence in
anything particular
i'll let um sahara um come in in a
minute but i think um
when we talked to the regional medical
director at nhs england
about the concept of
small hospital being attached to a
larger hospital means that your
the number of junior doctors a number of
uh
beginning starts to grow
for us as a as a small trust who can't
normally get those trainee posts in
so
um i'll leave sahara to answer the um
the sentence of excellence because i
think that i think she's already alluded
to one but it just means you have you
have more critical mass for training for
help for supporting trainees
particularly clinicians
once you're a larger trust
thank you um yes so what's up with that
i didn't know that is the fact we also
we already have some areas of surgical
particularly um uh upper
gastrointestinal intestinal uh where we
have an amazing team who really built
themselves a national
reputation and what we also have which i
think is really interesting is um we
have some really innovative service
models so the ways in which we've used
some of our physiotherapists and nurse
practitioners our pharmacists to lead on
and deliver key elements of services to
patients to make them more accessible
locally and not require them to always
travel to um the cities to
consultants um it's held up as an
example of where we can really
demonstrate to others how to do these
things um i think the advantage to us
if i can just allude to the merger for a
second
is um the new combined trust will be a
teaching trust that's the first thing to
remember
so we will be teaching justin who wants
to be or not um and what's really
interesting is the number of medical
students being rotated through this site
is going to triple over the next two
years moving from 35 a year to over a
hundred
which is both a blessing and a curse
given our local accommodation challenges
and the fact we won't build the
accommodation for 2024 but what it tells
us is firstly that the um the education
sector in the medical area university of
exeter i feel there is a real demand for
medical students to experience working
in this kind of environment where
instead of being a highly specialized
technical technological specialty
we have general management positions and
ranges of care
work that far exceed what they might
experience in a large hospital and
people want to have that breadth of
experience
so i think it's been a really positive
period for the hospital that there's
been recognition that center of
excellence isn't just about hologists
it's also about ways of working and i do
think that we can build on the initial
work that's been done in that area and
really create um some noise around some
of the amazing services that have come
on the spotlight during this integration
process
yeah i've got right
at this point i just want to say thank
you ever so much for your time because
you must be so busy um but i just wanted
to ask and i don't think this is
probably going to be appropriate we're
here for having heard the presentation
but it's about dentistry because i'm
really concerned about lack of access to
dentists in in our area um i assume
that's nothing to do with you guys but i
just wondered if it was worth asking
no i replied to the scrutiny officer
this really sits with the
clinical commissioning group who
commissioned dentistry
um but you know
if you want me to forward any question
to them i'm more than happy i know the
dentist commissioner
okay thank you very much
councillor woodhouse
um i just wondered with the um potential
expansion um that you were talking about
if there would be any scope to bring
back um some more specialist neurology
and cardiologists services or if that
will stay with exeter you don't
anticipate that coming back to north
dakota
or coming to north carolina
you go first i'll go first and you sweep
up after me right um so what i would say
is we are we have gone on initially on a
pathway by pathway review looking at
maintaining
our current services and that's been our
primary focus even in that exercise we
have already around some of our services
identified opportunities for
repatriating part of pathways having
said which i wouldn't want to set an
expectation that we're going to create a
secondary center of excellence
in an area where
it lends itself to having all the
specialists together in one place so i
gave the example earlier of hematology
you'll remember so hematology used to be
delivered by a single consultant um here
in north devon back until about
2007-2008
that was totally unsustainable dependent
on one individual and you couldn't
justify employing one individual for the
number of cases you would have to have
dealt with but by replacing that with a
jointly run service where the
hematologists are effectively all our
dne consultants but they then come over
and provide local clinics and outpatient
services here in north devon we have
kind of got the best of both worlds
and i think that's the right way to view
it so my simple answer is there's no
guarantee that anything will come back
at this point but every pathway as part
of the clinical integration will be
looked at to see what the benefits are
that can be leveraged through the merger
and whether given our local work
possible networks were better um we
believe that any part of the service can
be delivered better here another good
example actually was recently talking to
some of the oncologists about
radiotherapy you know radiotherapy is
delivered especially service to liver
exeter it will never justify putting in
resources to deliver that for the small
number
i'm
of
patients
this territory however
what we could do is deliver more of the
follow-up and preparation here at north
devon with a slightly different
constructed offer and some more virtual
support and that will come with the
rollout of the digital patient record so
definitely some improvements but i don't
want to offer what we can't guarantee
i think um i think that's
you know if you if you think of us as a
sort of island um you know the
remoteness makes us that island because
you've got to cross over them more to
get anywhere and your model of care
adapts and if you if we you know
zahara's right we're speaking to all of
the clinical needs and
what's unlocked as soon as you've got a
common
patient record is your clinicians can be
in exeter they could be anywhere but
they can be an exeter
on a virtual link to a north devon
patient and that that then becomes
really easy to see how local access can
be maintained without the physical
access needed to be there i mean it's
not a replacement don't get me wrong i'm
not saying that and it's got to be
mutually
you know consent with the patient that
that's the model of care that they
that's how they want to receive the care
but you can just start to see the
convenience start to be
really unlocked as well as delivering
access
i think the terminology the clinical
leave for integration used the other day
which i love with you say clinicians
will have real time access so literally
a clinician in exeter can look at a
patient record on a patient north devon
whilst on a call to the clinician in
north devon without having to wait for
somebody's email and results information
or technology they will be working
together on a single patient in real
time that i think will unlock great
local capacity
thank you councillor harding do you have
a question yeah uh good afternoon um
i've been known
as a signal i've had two hip operations
a new knee and a trigger bypass and
i've seen uh some of the
nurses and doctors work really really
hard
i have my um
triple bypass i've been cheap and uh it
was a new hospital and and the the
future looks fantastic i mean i didn't
go anywhere for an x-ray they brought
the machine to me um you know it was it
was that clever and and tech so it's
something to really look forward to uh
at our local hospital um
most of the time though it's
um we have the problem of housing and
she said you've got to do some uh
quarters therefore for the staff um how
much
how many uh quarters are you thinking
about doing because
you know there's families that would
like to move down from other hospitals
down to that country but
you know they don't think they can get a
house or anything like that down here or
give it a try i just want to know what
kind of accommodation you were looking
at um and uh and will it be a decent car
park because that's one thing that i
have had so many uh appointments and
i've had to be there so much earlier to
be able to park um so i mean that that's
the kind of thing i want to see in
design
i'm glad you're looking forward to new
shiny buildings because i have to say
it's lovely for both staff and patients
parking always my favorite topic already
the workers starting and surveying
existing and future car parking
requirements and they're interested in
the other upshots of kobe is the
capacity requirement on our car parks
and significantly reduced its more
virtual access
has been taken up on services not
surprisingly um can i just clarify on
the accommodation the only accommodation
the hospital provides is what we call
short-term staff and
support accommodation for visiting
clinicians so we don't provide housing
per se on here normally the our future
hospital money be allowed to use provide
housing
we are absolutely dependent on our local
partners local authorities and others
promoting housing development schemes
that will include affordable housing and
if that doesn't happen then we will be
challenged because what we do is we help
to bridge people into the area we
provide short-term accommodation for up
to 12 weeks to enable them to find
rental accommodation which i have to say
is in i say this because i'm a current
renter in the area having moved into the
area and still struggling to find
somewhere to buy it is a huge challenge
for people moving into the area and
unfortunately the nhs cannot divert
money from patient care to providing
housing that that's the one
that's definitely a no-go area
unfortunately so that comes back to our
partnership with all of you to try and
understand what the future denial will
be
and how it can best be men
thank you
thank you does anybody else have any
questions cancer laws please yeah can i
just come back to the basic bug bearer
parking you know you
you sort of have a superb hospital
uh the service that my family have
received there is
tremendous uh even in these hard times
you've been going through
but your shop window parking is always
going to be a bug bear
is there any possibility of buying more
land
you may need it in the future for other
purposes as well is there any land
available around it or is it just locked
in
um we are we are banned on two sides by
land uh one side privately owned one
side is actually i believe being
acquired by
housing therapists
and we're only party stacks but
obviously we have a shared boundary um i
go back to my early employment this site
is not fully utilized so that is a
recognition of how the site is organized
not whether or not we need more land so
um i think our estate team would argue
that with a better um layout and
management
and potentially a road system that
enables you to travel around the site
which we can't do at the moment because
our road only extends halfway around um
and looking at areas such as where the
helipad sits etc um there is a lot of
potential to change our car parking
situation so that's why i say car
parking always a joy always a challenge
um but also alongside car parking going
back to the sustainability question um
looking at e-charging points on site
which will become a topic of the future
but again also thinking about other ways
that people come to the site there's a
significant percentage of people who
live in north dakota that don't have
access to a car and we also have to make
sure that the one bus an hour perhaps
becomes a more accessible service so all
of those issues in the transportation
side will be being looked at but don't
assume just because we might have um
challenges in our car parking now we
won't be able to address those with our
existing site because we can
thank thank you
councillor
thank you um i just wanted to follow up
um on the care quality commission
inspections
um october 17 you had an inspection and
it was required improvement
may 19 of further inspection but there
were improvements still requiring
improvements in certain areas
now when you merge how will they deal
with north devon
district hospital
being in partnership with raw devon
extra how will that continued
improvement be monitored by the care for
the commission
so we come under one trust so there is
no there would no longer be a separate
um northern devon healthcare
uh registration for for the for with the
cqc
um in terms of how
the new combined trust would manage its
um cksd action plans they would continue
they have to because they are you know
they are they have action plans attached
to it
um i think what my earlier presentation
was trying to say is all of the issues
that are in the cqc report i've just you
know i've just covered it's the
workforce challenges it's the resilience
it's the um impact of patient safety and
continuity of care of opening a reliance
on locums
so
some of the issues that we're facing are
structural and they are about economies
of scale and we're hoping that with the
benefit of partnering with a large
apartment you start to get um you start
to be able to address them together so
it's it's not that they are dismissed we
take you know it because the cqc reports
are accurate and they reflect um our
reality
one further question
okay um a separate issue all together
i'm reading our parish profile
a 2019 which all councils are given
and have access to and i know that life
expectancy both for males and females
peaked in 2014 and slightly dropped
do you think that the future holds a
less
lengthy life for all of us or do you
think that trend will be reversed
that's way above my pay grade i'm not a
public health expert but
you know it's those figures are really
interesting we look at them
we all look at them because they are our
you know that that's our
these are our citizens that we're
designing services to to serve and
maintain people's health it is really
worrying i think covid has exposed
massive inequalities in health we have
life expectancy chances that are vastly
different across our community
and one of the challenges we have is um
and that we're putting our minds to at
the moment is when you when you recover
your waiting list and reduce your
waiting list how do you do that that
makes sure that inequalities aren't
baked in so that you you know you're not
you are prioritizing or you're seeking
out those people who haven't come
forward
and that have struggles um are
struggling to access care how do you
make sure
that you don't um you know you you
take the health inequalities of your
population um
you know into account when you're
designing your services i think
you know it's part of our board and our
board discussion at the moment um every
single time the board meets is that
challenge i suspect expect the councils
are exactly the same it's you know it's
really stark particularly in devon where
we've got a really high universal credit
uptake right at the beginning the
pandemic we're still seeing the impacts
of that on our community
another question sorry i couldn't hear
it
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you for your presentation
um i do have some concerns i've had them
for a long time about the north denver
healthcare trust
to me it's been a managed decline of
that trust over the years
and i do hate and i've heard it
mentioned
four or five or six times about the
remoteness of the hospital
in northern it's not remote to the
hundred and eighty thousand people who
live in the area
it might be a bit distant from extra but
then
the rdna is remote for us up here in
north dakota so don't keep all about how
remote we are as if we're at the end of
the world
now
questions i've got is
the combined trust because big isn't
always bigger isn't always beautiful and
doesn't always work better but the
combined
trust why should i have any more faith
in that
than the
they've been working together now since
2018 and yet
my colleague just mentioned the cqc
report published in november was a
reality really that the trust had gone
backwards and yet you've been working
together since 2018.
why should it be any better
once it's an official combined trust in
april
you're right um
if i just
some of these issues are really
difficult and they're really challenging
and the the board the northern demon
healthcare trust board
back in uh 2019 recognized that it
needed the help of a larger partner to
deal with them and you don't solve them
overnight uh you know if you speak if
you're speaking to any representative
from an nhs trust today they would be
talking about their worries about
workforce supply how they're going to
fill vacancies how they're going to
maintain their services because of the
workforce supply issues that we're all
facing so
this is not a problem new to north devon
you're absolutely right this is
something we're tackling on you know
tackling day-to-day
to make sure our services continue but i
think the the essence of our
plan is that you you we need support we
need support north devon needs the
support of a larger partner and all of
the resources that that brings and
expertise and sharing of resources to
make to start to address some of the
risks that you know are so publicly
recognized in the cqc report but you
know the board does not you know the
board doesn't shy away from
acknowledging them they are they are
challenges that we're owning all the
time
a lot of it's predicated on finance
isn't it because
you're looking to be making savings of
about 11 million pounds i mean
because the rd as well as north dam
hospital have got debts
yes both trusts reported deficit yeah
you're absolutely right
excellence or improvement that this this
is happening it's to save money as well
but it won't you know you're absolutely
right it won't address the murder all in
one sorry won't address the there's no
expectation that this would address the
deficit all in one go all in one year
there was a very slow and incremental
financial
motherboard so um you know
i think our shocker system by
the drive is you know best value and
efficiency for taxpayers we know that
demand never keeps you know the finance
never keeps pace with demand we know
that's the situation we've been living
in for for years um
yeah i think we're suspicious
i can tell
i think the suspicion of here with some
is that any savings will be at the cost
of the north dam hospital for people up
here can i ask you about bed spaces is
it
is it um
the plan to increase dead spaces
in north devon bearing in mind we've got
a very rapidly growing elderly
population
yes i didn't hear first part of the
question before the rapidly growing
elder population
is about bed bed numbers i think
rather than
reduction that's been going on over the
last few years
yes we will be adding more baits if that
was the question if you remember when i
talked about the main tower
refurbishment the priority for the
refurbishment is to create additional
inpatient capacity because we need to
because the growing population needs
having said which and i say this because
it's on my mind i mean spoke to somebody
this morning we just sponsored two
system workshops locally um with
community action groups local authority
uh bevan county council gp's primary
care community care and our acute
physicians to look at how we care for
our elderly people in the longer term
and future because there's no doubt by
the time somebody tips up at our front
door they're probably going to be here
for an inpatient stay and it's an
inpatient stay which potentially could
have been avoided had they been managed
slightly differently so we always have
to challenge ourselves to ask ourselves
there is a slight helplessness about
just reacting to demand all the time
we do have to challenge ourselves to see
if we can also manage demand because
going back to the earlier point the
resources will not grow to keep pace
with the draft but that is a fact of
life so we do have to be innovative but
yes we will need more impatient beds and
that is in our proposal
thank you finally
what do you see is the main problems
facing the combined trust from april
workforce
i think
but the workforce how do you get
trainees in post and how you recruit
zahara what's your challenge well
actually i would have said the same
thing but i think i would also reflect
the fact and it is worth setting this
context as much as we've talked about
our local challenge um if i talk to
friends as our oncology team there is a
shortage of cancer consultants
nationally so if you can imagine in a
limited pond that doesn't have enough
supply you're then all fishing for the
same fish and that's just it is
difficult even for the rde there are
workforce recruitment challenges so the
combined trust will have the combined
know-how wisdom
might and intent however it will also be
facing into what is a challenge that is
not going to go away for the nhs
generally which is the growth of service
demand is outstripping the supply of
healthcare professionals currently
thank you councillor woodhouse please
all right so it was um just going back
to um the increase in beds um i know
it's been found a lot that um
inpatient stay has been increased
because of rehab needs as opposed to
acute medical need and i wondered if
there was any scope for rehab services
or anything like that is have you got a
plan for them are you looking at
potential rehab units
with community hospitals and other
existing
structures and properties like that
i don't want to guess at the answer um
because i'm not familiar with the uh
length of stay specifically as a result
of uh rehab so i might have to say we'll
get back to you unless sahara you you
know the answer to that um i don't know
the specific answer i do know that
compared to national um standards uh our
length of stay is actually better than
most but nevertheless the increasing
delays in discharge
is a complex issue it's not just about
rehabilitation
so yeah i think kathleen's right he
wants to put out that strand
specifically probably have to talk to
the discharge team
um
yeah
okay thank you
i think it's fair to say on rehab
again i go back to the workforce
challenges always um you know our
community teams that do rehab um outside
of the hospital are always stressed
as indeed are the reagan teams from the
devon county council who work closely
with them because they do try and do
whatever they can outside of the acute
setting once acute care is finished but
gosh it's um
it's a stretch in service at the moment
yeah so it was just with regards to the
the recruitment and i understand um you
know you guys are saying that it's
difficult
um the adverts that i've seen um for
north devon recruitment wise
for clinicians they tend to focus on it
it's a lovely area there's really nice
beaches it's a great place to live as
opposed to this
new vision that you're you know you're
going to be a cutting-edge hospital
you're going to have this business so i
just wondered if you're looking at your
recruitment strategy
changing as well to accommodate
that change
yeah a lot of work going into that
because um and we target particular
cohorts of clinicians according to what
we know works um so you're absolutely
right you most um
it's quite difficult before you're
legally merged
to advertise
an employer that doesn't actually exist
so you're absolutely right all of those
marketing plans and all of the market
research has been undertaken and we know
what works but um you know we're waiting
till we merge
until we
launched launched that brand into the as
a recruitment brand but you you're
absolutely right
thank you
councillor bottle honking yes please um
i think it's brilliant to see all the
digital improvements and technology but
i have got concern about information
that's given digitally or over the phone
um because you talked earlier about
giving results over the phone um
or
um yeah remotely
um but if they're particularly bad or
terminal results which actually happened
to a friend recently
um she's given the results over the
phone shouldn't these always be given in
person and will they be given in person
in the future so i think it's really
important that they are
so i absolutely agree with that and
that's why i said there's a
transformational outpatient program
because the problem is kobe meant we did
some things in ways that we probably
wouldn't ideally want to and i suspect
the consultants if they were here in
front of you would say the same things
because they've had some pretty
uncomfortable moments as you can imagine
not as uncomfortable as your friend
necessarily but um absolutely now what
we're looking at is literally
pathway by pathway type of consultation
by type of consultation to try and work
out both by patient experience and by
clinical guidance the best way to offer
those the other thing i think probably
worth bearing in mind is we should
always be offering people the choice of
how they have their consultation so in
our ideal world this would be a
multi-channel environment where people
could choose to have it digitally online
they could have it by phone or they
could come face to face um and people
choose which works best for them because
you can't this isn't like a
a consumer market we could just
wholesale switch the way we offer
something and tell anyone to
bump it or go somewhere else we are a
national health service
so we absolutely have to look after our
patients
thank you
yeah
anybody else have any
all
questions
lovely well thank you very much for your
time today and we appreciate you are
very busy um i think the presentation is
excellent and it's been very informative
and
it's answered a lot of our questions do
you have any questions for us at all
i'll be able to answer them
my colleagues might
political support for some of what we're
doing is really important as is
collaboration across canada council and
um the nhs and it's just
it's just really to start that open open
dialogue with you we have quite
we hope hopefully we've thought of the
areas that we have in common in our
priorities in the presentation that you
know and it's just really to make sure
that you know we're we're really ready
to engage with the council about some of
these issues because for our community
and serving our community together is is
quite an important thing that we want to
be able to do together so i just
if it
it probably goes without saying but i
just thought i'd end i end up on a you
know note of partnership with you
lovely well thank you again both of you
for
taking the time to present to us and um
i don't think we've got any further
questions
no
well i think we'll say goodbye thank you
thank you bye
okay
the man's gonna do it for me
quite interesting quite informative
um
but then i also thought a lot of it was
almost common sense and
you can see staffing staffing staffing
yeah
yeah i think it's going to be an ongoing
issue forever we don't ever see
i think they don't contain stuff
particularly well as well i think that's
part of the inherent problem
the beauty of north devon hospital um is
1970s but it is
an open plan building so they can do a
lot of things
so if they build somewhere else first
and then they move things around they've
got school to
do things in it you know i was talking
to the nurses up there on many occasions
and uh you know they don't think that
he's knocking down they they just think
that you know the walls aren't fixed so
let's just move it around a bit i mean
it's a really big sight when you think
about it and the changes that have
happened in this probably the last seven
years from the seymour unit i don't i'm
lucky i don't visit very often but when
i have i'm like oh
yeah that's neat yeah
it's a very proactive uh hospital i mean
you know over and above and different uh
uh things there that they're all busy
trying to improve it i mean i think a
multi-story car park was definitely
needed
i know we're going around and running
around living with this park but um you
know it but you know it is
you know it is difficult here they are
hanged in i know they stopped the land
they can possibly acquire um but it's
gonna impossible a lot because
somebody's got their rights for building
on it
yeah this is like
buildings as well so if they're saying
about centralizing the admin potentially
to exeter then it might free up some of
the other buildings more clinical space
potentially i think they also suffered
from the insecurity factor when this was
first floating
five years ago now isn't it
um the staff were thinking oh here we go
we're going to end up i can carry my
product
[Music]
doing getting the records all on one and
getting
sorted out is a massive thing i know a
microsoft's busy addict
but it is something that's definitely
being doing because you know i had an
operation a troubled bypass waited for
the deal and they said you know they
couldn't work out why i was sent up
there because they couldn't see what
drugs i was on and they didn't believe
me they had to
you know it's a
it's no joined up thinking and that will
be a lot easier with that
that's a big shame as well that they're
not joined with the gp surgeries because
your initial point of contact is if
something's wrong everybody's got a
national health number so
they should be able to make that from
their own which make it all digitalised
yeah they currently come with the gps
but when i
see that inpatient system all the
inpatient notes they're not joined up
with the community notes so you would
then go and see patients out in the
community you couldn't actually access
any or what would actually happen to
them in the hospital unless somebody had
actually sat down and physically copied
it one from the other and
you looked at the different systems and
the money that was spent on it and you
know they had choice they were included
in it it was a consultation and you
think how
how do you choose to use systems that
don't work together
you just make one mistake in the middle
and it's not joined up from that
yeah
yes
the common fault of
um
is communication
anybody that
works once a household does anything
that break point of breakdown and
communication is where it goes wrong
anyway moving on item number nine
consideration of the forward plan
yes
can we contact
the person she said
because she said she knew who it was
could you do that and i mean i don't
know whether it's appropriate to put
that on the floor plan or whether to
just at this point make an enquiry of
them but
yeah
i'll work and do a bit of work for a
dentist and he was pulling his hair out
he asked me to talk to jeffrey cox a
long time ago but he has got people that
want to work for him he has got room in
his practice to put more dentists yet
the
nhs won't let him have it
because he's got his culture
yeah he's got people traveling up to red
roost to the hospital and people
traveling from plymouth to so obviously
and and he's still taking on or it was
taking on nhs and
people as well as private i know young
families in the area that cannot none of
them
can can get on a dentist list even the
children even privately
the children are i've got to go on a
private waiting list and that's just not
acceptable
so i mean i i would like to pursue that
if it's maybe even worse with cooper
because the ppe that our authenticity is
going to wear is 10 times more than
anybody else because they're looking at
but
did read something
either online or in one of the papers
and it was um talking about dentistry
around bastable and the lack of it
and installing around what it was
so i did look and think oh someone knows
um
i'll have to see if i can find out what
that was
right
so
where are we
2021 2022
january for every march so april um
we are looking at
sewage discharge and water quality
within the area um karen and janet made
contact with people at the agency the
environment agency that is and also
um southwest water no response yet
but it wasn't yesterday one day
yeah
it was only yesterday so we'll give them
another week
before we um
[Music]
when we register specific questions
that can be sent to them
in advance yeah we could do yeah and
that may give them a bit more
confidence is most probably not the
right word but make you feel a bit more
secure of what they're coming to talk
about
because i can imagine there could be
nothing worse than coming to a meeting
and you know you're going to get torn to
pieces
i don't think i'd want to go
you know they are human at the end of
the day if we can preempt
questions
i think that will make like we said we'd
address jd brenton's query or question
didn't we so i don't know if we need to
get that
exactly
[Music]
yeah i mean i think if we can give them
as much information that we're or what
we're requesting but at least they know
what they're walking into rather than
coming in blind
they can't have every answer to every
question if they don't know what the
question is to start with
and that's kind of how we work as a
council as well we don't answer the
question immediately if some member of
public asks we go back
and um
compile the question the answer to the
question
um i anticipate that's going to be an
interesting and insight exciting one
i'm looking forward to it
well that's as far as i go as april
winner
so
um we've got um june meeting your book
dear
um
and also yesterday today actually today
as well there's um a new drop-in center
opened in high street which is the
alabama
they've been around for absolutely
donkey's years and i'm just surprised
how many people haven't heard of them
i might not be pronouncing it i think i
am yeah
they've just opened a new drop-in center
in high street it's just up from new
look and i think there was a financial
advisor in there before i've been in
three times now just to
get a feel of what's going on and
what they're achieving and what they're
doing and what their needs are
um
i did mention to them to them this
morning about coming and presidenting to
us
because i think they're rather
overlooked i don't think they are
i've got this the um
i don't know not many people know about
them
[Music]
and somewhere else on the left in the
high street and they're just purchasing
another property in barnstable
and they
take
people that need accommodation and
support with accommodation and how to
find their feet and learn to life skills
we've done it and that's exactly right
and we work very close to our home
very closely
they're a very good local provider so um
if you want
something from there too
to speak
[Music]
yeah i've just um
emptied my
councillor's pot whatever's left i've
just donated to the drop in because they
said that's what's not attracting
funding at the moment they've actually
got a little well you can tap on the
window tap your card on the window
outside
um so you know they're quite up-to-date
on how you can donate and only this
morning i was in there there was a
elderly lady she just went in and just
gave her like 20 quid so she obviously
knew about what they were doing and
they've got a support worker in there
but they house people
not necessarily in your own community so
if you need to move away for whatever
reasons i met a very young lady in there
and she moved away from a family and had
been in the care system for a long time
but this was kind of a hard step to
independence it's almost
it does bridge a bit of a gap between
care leaving and going into
independence i just think they're
amazing they're really good good and
i've got some counsellor many there if
anyone wants to send me any details of
anyone
yeah i've sent them
last week late last week so um
you can just tag onto my form
because i tagged on to councillor gov's
form yeah because mine was spent before
and december when i got in so
[Music]
okay
a bit more specifics around what we
wanted to actually
uh achieve at the meeting so i suppose
the outcome
of having the meeting we wanted some
more detail on that so when i looked in
a meeting next week together so i was
thinking after that
we can contact
i think now we've kind of narrowed it
down to water quality
on the lack of water quality whichever
way we're going to call it i think it
will generate a bit more interest now
because obviously they've got issues um
in north devon as well
um
i mean they're welcome to join they can
join online can't they they can join by
soon
okay
they use teams hopefully wow
were talking
i just got lost at the end okay
are they going to be coming here to talk
to us
i'd like to pencil them in yeah let's
put them on the forward plan
because it's really good
um and i think janet will know all about
this they're
struggling with like emergency combat
accommodation
so if i was to become i needed
accommodation at five o'clock tonight
all of the agencies and services were
closed they couldn't have background
checked on me or a risk assessment so
you know i couldn't just go and stay
there because they don't know what risk
i would be
um so they're looking for sort of
emergency they did mention pogs
um where they could just
pop someone keep them dry warm and safe
and fed for the night until everything
opens up the next day and then they can
work with replacement
i don't know
that would be absolutely ideal i mean we
looked at the
containers didn't we
that were converted we looked
i know janet is already working once
will be coming back watch this yes
you know i i question whether it needs
to be applaud
modulus
is just something that's that's
self-conscious oh it
you know we've got an emergency room
somewhere in an establishment
we we have we've got
the hostels with but we're similar to
them we're struggling for our own
emergency accommodation but that
as jon's just said we're identifying
sites where we could potentially
situate um cons or modular accommodation
what they're called and that's going to
come forward to numbers
days that is
we're not sort of
it's not going to get better
it's going to get no it must be a
pessimistic
it's going to be difficult isn't it it's
difficult i think everyone's struggling
that the hospitals just said we're
struggling aloe vera is struggling it's
it's trying to find accommodation and
places where we can recite the
accommodation
right so that's definitely yes
[Music]
okay well we've got part two
anybody else for anything we want to add
or say
all right
[Music]
okay so that